and throughout the past year small
businesses all across the valley have
struggled to make ends meet
many have applied for the pandemic
emergency technical support or better
known as the pets grant
in order to stay afloat reporter kate
houston spoke to some businesses who've
been waiting on funds for months
and had quite the surprise this week
gone through all my savings
every bit of it debra montoya is the
owner of the beloved henderson flower
shop antique rose florist
she opened her family-run business in
1979
and says she's never gone through
anything like the past year missing out
on dozens of events
and tens of thousands of dollars i've
experienced everything for 42 years
and this has just been the worst like
montoya erin clafter phillips works an
aspect of the events industry
running a boutique catering company chef
kp creations
which specializes in everything from
private dinners to large events
due to initial shutdowns he lost out on
nearly forty thousand dollars over a
three month period
it definitely crumbled us pretty quickly
right off the bat i totally
understood from my standpoint but at the
same time it was it was one of the
biggest blows i've ever taken
although it's been difficult neither of
them gave up hope i've worked too hard
to be where i am today
and i'm not giving it up this week both
got a surprise zoom
with the best news you are going to
receive the best grant
selected for the group so you'll be
getting ten thousand dollars
i waited so long i'd spent six months
checking my email every day praying you
know that they would come through
um so it was a very nice awestruck
moment to get that phone call yesterday
and
to get that draft
all i need to do is say thank you they
plan to use the money for payroll ppe
repairs and to lay a foundation for the
future of their businesses
kate houston 8 news now that is a
lifeline for so many people in february
the governor signed assembly bill 106
which allocated 50 million more dollars
to that program
and that money will allow the
treasurer's office to continue to
process those
thousands of pending applications brian